-Our next guest is a forme
advertising executive, author,
and a regular
on MSNBC's "Morning Joe"
and "Deadline: White House."
New episodes of his podcast,
"On Brand With Donny Deutsch,"
are available Thursdays.
Please welcome back to the sho
Donny Deutsch, everybody.
♪♪♪♪
[ Applause ]
Thank you. Welcome back.
-Great to be back.
-Nice to see you! Human beings
-I -- I -- Look at -- Wow.
Hey, guys.
-It's a big deal, right?
It's not a lot of people.
-It's a big deal.
It's -- I --
You know, I come in 30 Roc
A couple days a week, you know
to do "Morning Joe"
and do Nicolle Wallace's show,
and I haven't been back sinc
March, whatever, of last year.
And I understand
this chair is new tonight.
-This is new.
-This is new. I love it.
-Yeah, you're the second -
our second chair guest
in over a year.
-I love it. I love it.
I love it.
-It's nice to have people
this close again.
It's a little strange
to look over a chair
to a person who had been mad
to sit in the center of a couch.
-You know, yes.
I have to tell you.
Being in the city,
the city feels alive.
-It does feel really different
-In the last week, I don't kno
if you guys feel it,
it just -- it's, like, popped.
And it just feels so damn good
It really does.
-It's really nice.
Now, I do have to ask.
Congratulations on your podcast.
-Thank you.
-But I think the question
anyone with a podcast
deserves to be asked is,
what made you think
the world needs another podcast?
-[ Laughs ]
You stole my open.
I was about to say,
"Not that the world
needs another podcast..."
-Right.
-They don't.
You know, the premise
of this one's, I think --
-It is a nice, specific brand.
-It is.
It basically --
The premise of the podcast
is that everything is a brand.
Every person, every politician
every product, every company
every religion,
every institution.
Anybody with a Facebook page
is a brand.
So every week,
I break down what are, kind of
I see as the ten brands
of the week.
It could be a person.
It could be a company.
And then I interview a big brand
in and of themselves.
You know, I've done
Michael J. Fox and Don Lemon
and Denis Leary
is dropping tomorrow.
And I got Hunter Biden
next week.
So we're doing a lot of --
a lot of fun people.
It's interesting.
-And, now, this --
You have a background
in advertising.
And is this
how you first started
seeing everything as a brand
-Yeah, I -- That's --
I've kind of had
an identity crisis in my career.
I've done a bunch
of different things.
So, for about 25 years, I ra
an ad agency, built brands
And then for the last 15 years
on television,
I've been kind of
analyzing political brands
and, you know, every brand
way -- which way, you know
kind of aspect in life,
where everything is going in
So kind of everything
has come together.
-Certainly, no one in politics
is more of a brand
than Donald Trump.
And it strikes me
that, right now,
the GOP is having trouble
being a brand independent
of Donald Trump.
Do you feel like that's even
an effort they're making?
And do you think it's an effor
that, if you were in charge,
they should be making?
-What I don't understand
about the GOP --
Because they are Donald Trump,
and beyond that,
they're not --
they're the party of "no."
The party of resentment.
They don't stand for anything.
What I don't get
is how dumb it is
because Trump is
a losing proposition right now
He's got 75% of the party,
which translates
to 30% of the population.
He's not electable again.
He cannot get any swing voters
So what I don't get is why
they're so beholden to him
in that it's a loser.
He's an absolute loser
going forward.
And that's beyond
the indictments that are coming.
Obviously, you talked about it
earlier in the show
with my old buddy
Michael Cohen --
about Michael Cohen.
But it's a loser.
But the party is lost.
They've fallen down,
and they can't get back up
-Now, I want to ask, as well
about the mayoral race
that's heating up in New York.
You had actually
at one time in your life
considered running for mayor
What made you decide
that was not for you?
-Um, I would have loved
to run for mayor.
I really think I could have been
a great mayor.
I love the city.
I grew up in Queens.
I could raise money.
I'm a centrist.
I just think, you know,
putting my family through it -
You know, it's a --
Donald Trump was a unicorn
Everybody goes, "Well,
Trump ran, and, you know,
he had all this stuff."
That was part of his brand
You know,
he was Teflon in that way.
And not that I've done
anything horrible,
but I have led my life
as a colorful private citizen,
and I just didn't need
all that color out there.
So I took a pass. I took a pass.
-Do you think New York
right now needs a --
You talked about being fro
New York and loving New York
Do you think New York's mayo
right now
has to be a cheerleader
for the city?
Do you think that enthusiasm
for the city
is what's needed post-pandemic
-Has to be a cheerleader,
has to be a builder,
and has to juggle in that
on the one sense,
it's a progressive city,
but on the other sense,
people want to be protected.
And they still, you know -
You know, we're not
a "defund the police" city
And it's a city
of businesspeople also,
and it's a city of everything.
So you need someone,
I think, down the middle.
Can't go too far left. Certainly
can't go too far right.
We operate best down the middle.
-Let me ask about the bran
of New York City
and how it has not been
effective for people
with presidential ambitions,
in that Giuliani, Bloomberg,
de Blasio all thought, "Hey,
if I could be mayor of New York,
I'd make a great president,"
and it seems like the rest
of the country said,
"No, thank you."
Do you think that's based
on the candidate
or based on the fact
that the rest of the country
is less enamored with
what it takes to run New York?
-I think
those are the candidates.
I mean, Bobby Kennedy
was a senator from New York,
and he would have won,
you know, I'm sure,
had that tragedy not happened.
I think it always comes down
to the human being.
I don't think
the country goes, "We --"
Look. We elected a peanut farmer
from Plains, Georgia.
You know, we elected a governo
who was an actor.
So it's the person.
I don't think New York
has a stigma --
"We can't elect a New Yorker."
It's just --
You named those critters,
and I think that was
the answer right there.
-Hey, I want to ask about,
you know, this last year.
And I think it's probably
a trend over longer
than just a year --
don't get me wrong.
But we've seen a lot of brands
get behind social issues.
Now, I think
one good question --
if it's anything more
than just surface presentation
of "we support these causes"
and maybe sort of empty tweets
and Instagram posts
as opposed to, you know,
actual initiatives.
But is this -- Are you surprised
that advertising has becom
so tied to the social issues
of the day?
-No, and they're not -- Look
I think most CEOs
are decent people,
but they're not necessaril
doing it from the heart.
They're doing it
from their bottom line,
in that, as you know,
every advertiser wants
18 to 34,
18, you know, to 49.
They're not going after
old fellas like me.
And young people --
that's price of entry for them
They want their companies
to have social consciousness
and so, you know, companie
used to stay out of it,
but now when it comes to thing
like basic things
like racial equality
and voters' rights,
you better be in there,
you know?
And what's interesting,
the companies --
Republicans used to be friends
of companies and vice versa,
and now it's the Democrats
so it's interesting to see
-Would -- Do you remember
your earliest ad campaign?
-My earliest ad ca--
Yeah, you know, I did a campaign
for the local Pontiac dealer
Remember the dealer
association ads?
Remember the good old guys
and things like that?
If you're from New York,
you'd know that.
-Was this a case where
you were putting dealers -
car dealers on TV?
-Yes.
That --
I come from humble beginnings.
[ Laughter ]
If you can do business
with car dealers,
you can do business
with anybody.
But one of my earliest campaigns
I'm most proud of
was for IKEA furniture.
And we show -- this is '93 -
a gay couple,
two dudes shopping
for furniture,
just matter of fact.
And at that point, you just --
you didn't see it on television.
You had Billy Crystal on "Soap."
You didn't see it.
I got so many letters
from people saying just
thank you for just
showing guys, you know?
It was a breakthrough campaign
something I'm very proud of.
-Well, it's really nice,
as always, to have you here.
Thank you for coming back
to the building for us.
-Appreciate it.
So great to be back, man.
-It's nice, right? It's nice
to be around human beings.
Thank you so much.
New episodes of
"On Brand With Donny Deutsch
are available Thursdays
across all podcast platforms